welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for this opportunity to engage with
our panelists on the everyday challenges
of being a parent in a non legal State
it's my pleasure to introduce our
participant who will be available to
answer your questions following this
discussion our panelist is Leah jerker
for more information about our
participant please refer to the speaker
bibliography in the center of your
screen my name is dr. Ken Crowley and I
will be the moderator for this
discussion this session is interactive
so please submit your questions by
clicking on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and type your questions into the
drop-down box we will address your
questions via email following the
discussion lyla jerger
is the wife and mother of five children
when her daughter
Jayla was diagnosed with epilepsy Lyla
became active in Indiana politics to
legalize cannabis therapies because of
the involvement of Child Protective
Services for using cannabis therapies
she had to move her family to Colorado
to be safe Jayla is currently using
cannabis therapies for epilepsy Lyla is
a volunteer for the realm of caring and
is still actively involved in cannabis
legislation so I'd like to introduce
Lyla now can you just tell us your story
of what it what led you to consider
cannabis as a treatment option for your
daughter and when Jayla was first
diagnosed with epilepsy
we had the discussion over the phone
with her neurologist about the different
form
chuckles that we could have chose for
Jayla and I just remember it's been over
a year but I remember the phone call and
I remember her going into the discussion
about the diagnosis and then for the
next five minutes we discussed
pharmaceuticals and the different side
effects and what it could do to her and
you know infertility was one of the side
effects and kidney stones and kept
rearranged and we just thought you know
there's got to be something better out
there there's got to be something safer
that's gonna do the same thing and
that's when we my husband supports
cannabis use and he brought it up to me
and at first I was not okay with it but
after my own research and talking to
other parents and people in similar
situations like ours I it seemed like
the best choice to go to the safest
option for her did you use people in
your local area to ask those questions
or were you reaching out to other pair
around the country a lot of it was
in-state discussion I met two wonderful
mothers who had already fought for
legislation in Indiana and they were
great with information on what we can do
I obviously talked with the makers of
what we what product we used and it got
into contact with other families that
were using it via that it wasn't just
Indiana people it was Florida and a
different states that we had talked as a
mother of for me what were the concerns
besides dealing with the legality of
cannabis administration to one of your
children what the other kids are the the
other kids they obviously played a big
role in the decision that we were going
to make
um we had no idea that we would run into
the legal issues that we ran into
I bought the oil that we were using from
a doctor in Indiana so I I didn't see
anything wrong with the legalities of it
when we first started her on it they the
kids themselves they just wanted the
seizures to stop we all just wanted the
seizures to stop no matter what what it
took realizing that our audience and
myself are already having a zillion
questions surrounding the prescriber
having access to the oil can you shed a
little light on us that scenario it was
a we we went to a functional Wellness
Center and the southern part of Indiana
he is a chiropractic neurologist is what
title he went by it was a function as
wellness center with a great reputation
and the doctor himself had a great
reputation and he is the one that he
looked at Jayla zeg he had all of the
information that he needed to make a
decision and to make a recommendation
and that's what his recommendation was
was they oil and then a couple of other
supplements that she would be taking
that's remarkable because that licensed
health care provider in that state was
really bucking the system was he at the
time let's be clear that was at the time
yes he completely bucked the system and
was on our side now once Child
Protective Services got involved he kind
of rescinded a little bit and was like
oh I would never tell them not to take
the pharmaceuticals and yeah I sold him
the the oil but I
you know there was a lot of he had a
different story once it came to talking
to CPS how did that impact moving
forward once you have the material once
you started treating your daughter maybe
we should look we should start with
describe how you incorporated that into
Jayla's routine how old was she at the
point in time that she started cannabis
what grade was she in kind of give us a
little bit of that background how you
how you integrated it into her lifestyle
it was really easy to integrate it Jayla
was 17 months old when we got the
diagnosis she was 18 months old when we
started the cannabis therapies we just
we found I guess we got lucky and she
likes the flavor of it and she doesn't
have any issues taking it at all
so introducing it for that went into her
morning routine was pretty simple and
doing it at nighttime was pretty simple
she's a pretty easygoing kid and the
product that we use thankfully she likes
the taste of it so there wasn't school
involved someone else challenge was you
could control it in the house what what
initiated child's protective services
how did that start
so Jayla got the diagnosis in July of
2017 and when we got the diagnosis we
were seeing a we were going to a rundown
Children's Hospital up in Indiana they
they didn't approve of it they wanted
her on a pharmaceutical obviously we
told him that we wanted to try this
let's see how it goes if she has a grand
mal seizure then we will
into your options but for now this is
working it's it's working we were seeing
the change in Jayla we were seeing the
improvements cognitively and the
decrease in seizures so we didn't see
any point and adding another regimen
when we were already getting such great
control so and it turned out that we
wanted to get a second opinion because
we had learned about this doctor in
Louisville Kentucky that supported the
use of what we were using the support of
the use of cannabis though we we reached
out to them and we got the second
opinion and at that point my husband and
I knew we had to decide you know are we
gonna stick with this doctor in
Louisville Kentucky or are we gonna go
back to the Children's Hospital in
Indiana and we called I called up to
Riley's Hospital and asked them if they
would be willing to do a 24 hour video
EEG for Jayla because we wanted to know
we wanted to see that it was working so
we requested ourselves the video EEG and
I got off the phone with a nurse and she
said yeah we'll do it no problem at all
and I said okay if you guys are gonna do
it and you guys are gonna support our
use then I guess we're gonna stick with
you guys up in Indiana and that was
around noon on September 23rd at 4
o'clock on September 23rd I got the
phone call from the nurse the social
worker at the hospital in Indiana saying
that we were reported the Child
Protective Services because of our
refusal to use pharmaceuticals so what
happened then Child Protective Services
came the next day to our house they
showed up at 9 o'clock in the morning my
husband was at work it was just me and
my daughter and I called my husband he
came home from work real quick we let
him in we didn't think we were doing
anything wrong
but not letting them in would have
probably caused more problems than good
when they came in we talked to the
caseworker by then Jayla was actually on
a very very low dose of Capra we had put
her on it as a second second
recommendation from the doctor in
Louisville he had suggested that we put
her on Capra
there's no low dose that kind of help
and get her completely seizure free
because she was still having maybe
10-mile clinics a day so the low dose of
heparin was supposed to just kind of
knock them all out and ended up not that
was not the case we had an increase in
seizures on keppra we had ever arranged
Jalen would walk around the house and
just cry or absolutely no reason just
cry walking around the house we didn't
know what was wrong with her we didn't
know how to fix it she wasn't sleeping
it was horrible
so we actually wanted that I wanted her
off the capra and we had already been in
contact with our doctor to make it
happen and when the object of the Child
Protective Services showed up we had
already you know started weaning her
back down and everything else the
caseworker came in and she asked about
jalis situation she asked about her
condition she asked about the medicine
that she's on I showed her the bottle of
keppra I showed her that some the
medicine was gone she had been using it
obviously and she listened to it I asked
her I said do you know anything about
epilepsy or do you know anything about
this treatment that we're using and she
looked me straight in the eyes and she
said I have no clue about any of it
I said well have you spoken to any of
the doctors yet and she said no I
haven't because we haven't gotten ahold
of the doctors yet okay so you're here
simply on a voicemail that that the
nurse had left for the caseworker and
she said yes
and I said okay so I came to
for a dummy session on epilepsy and
cannabis therapies and everything like
that and she said okay let me go stop
with my supervisor and she did she came
back in 30 minutes later after sitting
in our driveway on the phone and came
back in with this little post-it of what
we are supposed to do in order to keep
our daughter and one of the stipulations
was that we had to keep her on the capra
we were not allowed to take her off the
keppra number two was we could only see
one doctor and that was the doctor that
they chose and number three was that we
would take our daughter to get weekly
lab draws to prove to them that we were
giving her the keppra and if we didn't
do any of those they would take her and
all of our children so that had to be
heartbreaking frustrating realizing that
you had already seen a failure of
therapy a worsening of the condition so
one that wasn't a health care provider
was requiring you to do something that
wasn't helpful and probably harmful for
your daughter with no skill set in even
making those decisions medical decisions
for you and your daughter so what did
you do next we refused to sign the paper
we refused to sign it and got a lawyer
and actually I contacted I I'm gonna be
straightforward I hate politics I hate
it it's a game that I did not want to
play and um we reached out to a senator
that is close to us we actually thought
he was our senator but it turns out he
was not we are not in his district he
went to bat for us he he came to our
home he met us he met Jayla he is
completely in support of the therapies
that we were using
he's like you know this is why we passed
the law to allow epileptics to use it
and you know just because Jayla's
condition was not the epileptic
condition that they wanted that doesn't
mean that it wasn't working that doesn't
mean that it wasn't helping he went to
bat for us he he put his name on the
line and he called the governor's office
himself he called the director of Child
Protective Services I don't know what he
said I don't know why he did but he was
able to get our case closed within two
weeks and really yeah we had to take
Jayla to get one lab draw to prove that
she was on the cap right and then they
they ended up closing her child
protective case because of the senator
who went to bat for us and stood up for
us that's just an amazing story so I
guess the next step would be what force
do you not have to move to Colorado
after our initial case we did file a
lawsuit against the state of Indiana for
violating our rights one of the rights
that the Fourth Amendment right when
they drew Jayla's blood without a court
order they had no right to make us do
that but we were absolutely cornered if
we did not take Jayla to get that lab
drawn that day they would have gotten a
court order and they would have taken
all of our kids they made that very
clear to us so we had to we had to take
her for at least one lab draw we after
that our attorney was like okay the case
is closed now what do you guys want to
do and they can't they can't do this to
families they can't put other families
through what they put us through not not
having any idea they have no medical
experience of all how can they make
recommendation
on how we treat our child or what we do
for her that should be between us and
her doctor' and how our lawyer suggested
the lawsuit against the state of Indiana
and we're like you know what it may if
it'll make a difference if it'll change
how they treat one family then we're
gonna do it so we filed a lawsuit
against the state of Indiana and within
the year the case happened in September
we left in June we had Child Protective
Services at our house for six other
times and it was not for the cannabis
use it turned out it was it was any
excuse they showed up one day at our
house at 7 o'clock in the morning with
police officers because they suspected
that I was abusing my husband and that
we were doing other illegal drugs so any
evidence whatsoever it was and we were
using illegal drugs or we were abusing
the kids or we didn't have enough food
in the house or I mean it was just one
excuse after another for them to come to
our house it was one excuse after
another we came to Colorado in May to
meet the family for a vacation while we
were here we discussed moving the
Colorado and to be able to try different
therapies because we knew we couldn't
give our daughter straight THC in
Indiana because it was illegal we
couldn't go to jail for that so we knew
it was illegal to give her other
cannabinoids specifically so that we
knew that if we wanted to treat Jayla
and we wanted to be safe that we were
gonna have to make him remove um so we
decided when we got back home that we
were gonna go we set the date for June
16th we visited them in May in June we
decided we were moving
though June 16th was the day that we
were supposed to leave on June 15th
while everyone was at our house helping
us pack up and get ready to go and load
the uhaah I received a phone call from
Child Protective Services again saying
that they were coming they needed to
speak to us they had new allegations I
got my kids in the car we left that
night um we didn't get to say goodbye to
anyone we didn't get we didn't get
anything we got in our car we left that
day before meeting with them for the
last time that is that's just amazing it
it's painful to hear this story and to
listen to the abuse that these agencies
inflict where they don't have any
responsibility but they've given they've
been given the power to be able to
engage in a way that is not the
intention of that entity it's to protect
not to harm exactly I guess let's hear
what you did once you got to Colorado
I'd like to know where the lawsuit went
and if there was any modification to
focus on CMS's you know broad reach that
it seems like it's almost criminal in
nature as far as harming you know your
daughter and in your family and talk a
little bit about the formulation that
you used in Indiana and ultimately what
you arrived at once you got to Colorado
the lawsuit is still pending I don't I
know
member off top of my head what the exact
amount was that we were we were suing
for for the violation we offered them a
settlement back in December for $50,000
and they refused it
so it's ongoing the case has not been
closed yet we're still waiting to hear
from a judge as to whether or not he's
even gonna hear the case and at the time
if he does decide to then I will be
traveling back to Indiana by myself to
represent Jayla in the case and and see
where it goes hopefully it does because
like I said if it makes a difference for
one family and and that agency I'm
realizing that they can't do this to
families they have no idea the trauma
and the exploit that experience of time
to either one of my children I've had to
hold my eleven-year-old while she just
broke down and cried thinking that they
were gonna take her away they they have
no idea so if they can just know what
they've done maybe it'll make a
difference for the next family we don't
know so the case is still pending and
we'll just see where it goes from there
in Indiana we were using Charlotte's Web
and we continue to use Charlotte's Web
here in Colorado we did children behind
in Indiana one of them is still there
and that part of it's hard it's hard for
my husband and for my other kids but now
that we're here in Colorado we are able
to discuss it I mean our doctors still
can't say oh you need this this this
mess or they can't prescribe it they
can't tell us what to do
but they can support us they can kind of
off-the-chart guide us but mostly it's
the different families that we talk to
and then
bombs that are and the dads that are in
the same boat that we are that may have
the same diagnosis of do syndrome they
may have a different diagnosis of
epilepsy but they know they've been here
a lot longer than us they have a lot
more experience hands-on than we do so
it's just kind of trying to fit find
what what works for jail and what
doesn't
cognitively jail is doing amazing here
she has went from a vocabulary of a 12
month old to a three year old since
September of last year so cognitively
she's leaping and bounding with the
therapies were able to the cannabis
therapies were able to use here the
seizure reduction is still a 90% no
we're not at a hundred percent yet we
know that we have to try we're not we're
not done trying different cannabis
therapies and seeing what works for
Jayla and what doesn't work for her that
is absolutely an amazing story so your
family is still being impacted by the
situation one question that comes to
mind is are you considered a fugitive
not that I know of when we first moved
here I got a lot of phone calls from
Child Protective Services still it
lasted for about a month a month and a
half I would receive phone calls from
them our attorney advised us not to
answer it not to answer phone calls not
to reply to them they did not have a
court order
when we left Indiana they did not have a
court order so our attorney says that we
are in the clear thank God for small
things yeah
well if we would have waited if we would
have waited that could have been a
completely different situation it could
have been completely different because
they showed up at 6 o'clock the day
before we left so if they would have
showed up and they would have taken our
kids that day because all they have to
say is that they believe our children
aren't in immediate danger so if they
would have showed up at our house and
they would have taken our children that
night we would have been stuck and I
mean stuck in here okay I can't even I
don't know what I would have done to us
I really don't I'm sure all of our
attendees are probably going to give you
a number of questions and I and I look
forward to following those answers and
also following this pending lawsuit I
you know my my reach around the country
touches many that have been harmed by
the system they have found a successful
treatment and that treatment is
considered illegal or harmful many times
because of the ignorance of the medical
profession or like Child Protective
Services that just doesn't understand
how harmful their behavior is on a
family unit and I'm the father of six
kids you know going on 44 years of
marriage and and I and I have worked in
the area of children with with attention
deficit hyperactivity disorder and some
of the challenges that those parents
have had to go through with just feeling
with something that is that has some
valid therapies but cannabis has also
made a huge difference in many of those
so absolutely
you do you have anything further to
share with our audience um a lot of
people ask how hard it is to move that's
a question that I get asked the most how
everybody makes it seem like it's so
easy like they're like just pick up a
move if you're in a legal state and if
it's illegal just pick up and move go to
a legal state it's not even me not some
it's not any getting your car and go
type of situation it takes thousands of
dollars it takes planning it takes it
takes so much out of you to move to
illegal its to illegal States I don't
regret it
um I don't regret for a second moving to
Colorado it's been amazing for all four
of the children that are here in
Colorado with us obviously the one back
in Indiana is he doesn't get to see us
and we don't know how that affects him
emotionally he's still too young to
really express it too much or probably
didn't even know how he feels but it's
not simple it's not easy so when you
tell someone that is and then in an
illegal state to just pack up and go you
have you have no idea we're doing we're
and we're doing our best our absolute
best have you reached back out to that
senator that was supportive initially
that helped take the CPS off of your
back initially I'm actually working
behind the scenes on a couple different
laws that I'd like to change not only
cannabis laws but for epilepsy so I'm
still in contact with the legislators
there I continue to be involved in the
cannabis movement we have a huge rally
going on 4/20 up at the Statehouse it's
it's a celebration of people who they
still use it in an illegal state and
they're not afraid to hide it and
they're not ashamed of it because it's
helping them
um so Jayla's story will be introduced
there again
her grandparents are going to the state
house for her that day to be her little
guardian eatos up there and make sure
that they don't forget about her and
what they did to her well our thoughts
and prayers are with you and your family
and the effort that your your continuing
to push on you know I think this is this
is so heart-wrenching to me as a
clinician and as a parent what you've
had to go through and I applaud you and
so does everyone else for you continuing
to move this forward so that other
families don't need to go through the
trauma that you and your children and
husband have had to go through I think
the agency's overreaching when they had
no no right to and my response to that
would be that it we are absolutely doing
what what we think is best
why science has proven to us is
effective and if anybody judges or
anybody has a problem with it they can
live one day in our life and they'll see
what it's like and it's not easy and
it's not easy to make a decision for
your child but that's what we're doing
thank you so much Lila for sharing your
story and we wish you the best of luck
as time moves on and we find out how
this engagement with Indiana and CPS
moves forward with your lawsuit now I'd
like to introduce our next panel
list Jill swing which is the president
and founder of South Carolina's
Compassionate Care Alliance she lives in
Charleston South Carolina and has 11
year old twins Winfield and Mary Louise
what I'd like to ask you first Jill is
can you tell me how you got into the the
necessity to use cannabis in a state
that it's illegal it
sure absolutely so like he said I have
11 year-old twins and my daughter Mary
Louise has severe epilepsy and cerebral
palsy she was diagnosed with we noticed
she was having delays in some unusual
head movements about at about eight
months and we were referred by her
pediatrician to several specialists
including a neurologist who then
diagnosed her with cerebral palsy but
was unsure about whether she was
actually having seizures or not it took
another year to get that diagnosis and
another neurologist and more testing and
and when we found out she was having
seizures she had multiple delays and I
was actually kind of relieved because I
thought okay this is great we'll get it
on seizure medication and we'll get the
seizures under control and she'll start
progressing and and you know be catch up
to her brother or hopefully but that
wasn't what happened and do you feel
like this is a story I've heard from
parents across the country with children
with similar conditions we tried when
medication and then another and then
another and multiple combinations of
medications you know we actually own one
of her medications or a couple of her
medications actually made her seizures
worse one of our medications they
decided to just push the dose the
maximum level and what few little words
she was saying and some sign language
all of those skills actually went away
so the traditional not really
traditional I guess the
they're not traditional traditional
meaning the more plant medicine I guess
but the current medication
pharmaceutical models were not
successful and we had heard about a
little girl in Colorado who had found
relief from high and moody and low in
THC and about that time there were other
states that were passing these bills it
was kind of a legislative trend that
that they were passing the CBD only for
epilepsy only bills and I was fortunate
my mother-in-law had a her state senator
they had a mutual friend and she shared
that story and so they met and
introduced the CBD bill in 2014 which we
actually got passed but what did
although we could legally possessed even
oil in our state it didn't provide us
with any sort of source so what happened
was it just burst moms like me onto the
black market in order to obtain
medication for our children and so we
were you know networking through other
parents through social media through you
know a friends friends neighbor has a
son who lives in Oregon I mean we were
just reaching out and trying to get
anything that we could possibly get our
hands on because we were desperate to
help our children and there just wasn't
anything else available that was helping
but we were skilled things you know
there wasn't much in the way of testing
so we were sold things we didn't even
know we were fit for human consumption
let alone whether they would have any
therapeutic benefit and and and you know
we were paying top dollar for these
these you know products and we find out
that we were sold things that had no
trace and will mount the CBD and then
whatsoever or that they were you know we
got one product that was CBD a instead
of CBD and kids were losing seizure
control and so it was just a real you'd
finally get what you felt was a safe
reliable source that seemed to have
some benefits and then that person would
disappear because you know it's illegal
it's illegal for them to ship across
state lines and so you know we you know
we got wise after a while we were like
okay we want you know labs we want
labeling and labs and we became more
sophisticated consumers more educated
but even with that we were stole things
that didn't have CBD in them we were
still think even though they had them
labeling it was an accurate and we were
fortunate that we had a parent in a
legal state who had access to a
laboratory that could do this testing
for us so anyway so with all of that
what I learned very quickly is because
of the federally illegal 'ti and the the
challenges of every state you know it's
kind of an island on this issue that we
really needed a comprehensive medical
cannabis program within our state that
has you know cultivation process being
laboratory testing and so that is what I
started working on back in 2015 our
first comprehensive bill was introduced
then and I was networking with a lot of
other parents and a lot of other
patients who were you know interested
and and saw the medical benefits and
also needed you know access to medical
cannabis and what I realized was you
know we're patients where parents but
we're not lobbyists and well we are
whether we choose to be or not but I
guess what I'm saying is is that I
learned very quickly that most people
don't even know who their elected
official and you know let alone how to
get in contact with them and then why
don't you get in contact with them what
do you say once you are in front of them
you know and nobody wants to say well
I'm using this now illegally you know I
mean that's scary
so that's when I created my organization
so that we could provide education for
patient
inter advocate teaching in giving them
the tools and the resources that they
need to be successful advocates for
themselves or their loved ones that's
how the organization came about now
going back directly to your question
about cannabis use but we we did finally
get um you know the federal farm bill of
2014 passed and slowly but surely you
know CBD under hemp became more more
accessible but what I found was that
there although there were mild benefits
it wasn't really a homerun for my
daughter and you know we tried different
you know different products and you know
again we're flying blind Aleve there's
no physician guidance on any of this
they don't know anything about dosing
and you know were it's just the parent
network I mean we're really you know so
it's if online doctoring I guess I two
summers ago I took my daughter to me so
that we could actually have access to
whole plant medical cannabis treatment
under a doctor's care and guidance they
have a guest certification program you
have to jump through a few hoops with
their medical marijuana Department and
your own doctor but we were up there for
a month and we added THC to my
daughter's name we regime and I will say
she was not completely seizure free but
all of her high frequency myoclonic
seizures which she'll have you know
hundreds of those a day as well as drop
seizures almost completely went away and
the thing that I was so struck by well a
couple of things one she was really
stable and with her species low tones so
she's super wobbly and she can't stand
independently she can't relieve them
because she just falls over and she has
dropped Caesar so it was actually
dangerous and I've got pictures ever
independently sitting independently and
that's something I wouldn't have even
anticipated would have happened so that
was exciting and then she was so much
more alert like she was looking around
like she was seeing the world for her
for the first time and she was
babbling which was something she never
really did even as a baby so some of the
effects and things that I hadn't
anticipated you know beyond seizure
control were to me the most pounding as
far as improving her quality quality of
life that is just an amazing story were
you challenged at all during this time
by Child Protective Services now
fortunately I haven't had any negative
interactions with that I have a you know
are I've worked very closely with our
lawmakers I spend a lot of time in
Colombia at our State House and I'm
pretty well known and well respected I
have a excellent rapport with our law
enforcement folks who are adamantly
opposed to legalizing medical cannabis
but to be clear I don't haven't done
anything illegal within our state so
when I treated her with the THC that was
while we were in Maine so unfortunately
wasn't something I could really bring
you know back to her safely so no but we
have had parents who have treated their
children with CBD in our state who who
have had their children taken away from
them not understanding people they just
looked it up and said oh this is the
cannabis plant business cannabis even
with CVD it has it has been an issue for
some within our state recognizing that
THC
definitely improved things when you left
after a month and at some point didn't
have that product they line in their
condition or was that something that
hung around following that
discontinuance when we got we did do
some adjustments with her pharmaceutical
drugs have been helpful
but the stability on she can't she can't
I mean she comes just early wobbly again
and and that's something that's really
important I mean she was doing I'm
walking it in in the assistance and
losing mobility is just a heartbreaking
thing for a parent to have to watch
their child go through and she is in a
wheelchair at school mostly for safety
and transport at home I can I can walk
her with assistance I hold her arm but
she cannot walk independently she can't
stand independently so that was one of
the things that is I feel like you know
gosh I could at least do that that would
be amazing
I know that there's families out there
that defy this system once they see the
value of the therapy whether or not it's
legal in their particular area that they
live in is this something that you're
willing to risk in order to improve your
your child's you know long-term success
well let me say this I it's a decision
that no parent should ever have to make
and the fact that it's legal in 33 state
and it's not legal in South Carolina
just because of my zip code I can't
treat my child with a medication that I
know is effective for her is it's just
wrong it's just morally wrong and that's
why I'm continuing to change the law and
you know that's something that I don't
feel comfortable doing but I do know
that parents in our state are having to
make those decisions every day they are
having to take those risks and it's
scary I mean it's scary it's a little
different I think for an adult patient
to make that decision for themselves
versus when it's a child and you risk
losing the child
my child would never survive in foster
care there's just no way I mean and so
like I just I can't risk that because
it's a grater it's a really a greater
risk than you know watching her struggle
yeah that's hard but you know she's
she's she's okay you know I mean we have
good days and bad days and we're just
making it through the best we can until
we have legal access you know to to
medical cannabis so this is just
heart-wrenching to hear this story
you know the one from our earlier
panelists and and now this it just makes
me angry as hell and it is it's so
frustrating especially for a parent to
have to endure this kind of situation
when you know that there's something
that would make hurt you the quality of
life of your child better without
harming your child which is which is one
of the reasons why cannabis is such a
valuable therapeutic tool it's a
adaptogenic herb it helps a rather allow
the body to arrive at homeostasis
it has a broad therapeutic index there
isn't any real toxicities that stay
around once a dose that may be too high
for that individual or causes another
adverse event from consuming that
particular dose or ratio of cannabinoids
or route of administration could cause
once you remove the exposure there is no
long-term sequelae no long-term
damage ever-so onions is is there
anything that we can do to help you in
your effort to make a change in South
Carolina every state is an island like I
said earlier I just returned from acing
unity conference Americans for safe
access I just got back from DC late last
night and was reminded that you know the
push just cannot be continued to be on
the on the state level that we really
need to fight on the federal level you
know things are happening with the UN
they just met this week in Austria and
that is going to be marijuana is going
to be rescheduled unfortunately because
of the timing and the way their
procedure work it was going to happen
next year at their conference so that's
in the pipeline I mean that gives the
opportunity for the United States to
re-examine the scheduling of candidates
but you know we've got to have change on
the federal level for some of these last
lagging states like South Carolina who
you know we've got lawmakers who don't
want to create a state law that it
directly opposes federal law you know
that's one of the hang-up and then you
know I just I I want to remind people
who are in legal states I mean some of
these legal states have been up and
going for a really long time and I think
you know I have these conversations on
on social media and they forget you know
they're so used to it it's just a way of
life for them and they forget that there
are people out there who don't whose
still don't have access to this
medication and I think it's hard for
them to relate so I just want to remind
people out there that you know there are
those of us who are you know who are
back home still fighting the good fight
and you know just a love and support you
know sometimes that goes a long way for
us
Mama's that are still hanging on and
still fighting well I hope that our
audience can do something out there in
order to help further this wonderful
cause that you've taken on to take care
of your family and in help so many
others I'd like to thank our panelists
for their informative answers and thank
you to our wonderful audience today for
your thought-provoking questions you may
continue to submit questions and our
speakers will follow up via email that's
all for now thank you for joining us and
we will see you next time